federal reinforcements arrive
and helicopters hover above
the ethiopian government has maintained
that this is a law enforcement operation
against what it calls a treasonous group
our morale is high we're ready to
enforce the rule of law for the sake of
the fallen
we will prevail over those who had
betrayed them we have another mission
namely to safeguard the renaissance dam
until it's fully completed and
operational
this building has been set up to receive
fighters from the tigrai people's
liberation
front who've surrendered ahead of prime
minister abby ahmed's wednesday deadline
for the tplf to put down its weapons
government forces here say this man was
among those who surrendered
we are being treated well we are not
enemies we are all fellow ethiopians we
are all brothers
i hope this will come to an end and
peace prevail across the country
as fighting continues in northern
ethiopia for a third consecutive week
the tplf leader has reiterated his
rejection of the ultimatum
and says his fighters will continue
their struggle against the federal
government
until the end
on the other side of the battlefield in
mecca the tplf says it's standing its
ground
and that its fighters are ready to die
defending tigrai and its right to govern
itself
there are conflicting claims of victory
on both sides and a communication
blackout in the region makes it
difficult to verify information
but prime minister abhi ahmed has said
this operation will end when the tplf
who he accuses of destabilizing the
country and undermining his leadership
are brought to justice hassan razak
tigrad province in northern ethiopia